there's nothing in the post today and
just an outside chance a draft order is
on its way
but meteor won't risk it
you're going to get on a plane tonight
to go to Belgrade you might say goodbye
to your country forever
I'm not going to do that
I'm somebody here
and uh elsewhere I'm just like a very
very
nobody's character you know and I'm not
really wanted anywhere lots of European
countries are now discussing whether or
not to allow people like you in
um what do you think of that I think
that unfortunately if your stick to
uh
uh sort of the narrative that you're
choosing you're chosen like we are
liberals or I know we are for freedoms
and rights then you should stick to that
narrative and that means you should
allow people in or if you do not allow
these people in you're not you no longer
stick to the narrative that you're like
fighting for sort of supporting Ukraine
mitcha will be out by the time this airs
one of the lucky ones as tens of
thousands Queue at land borders fearful
that they'll be drafted on exit
but there are plenty who are prepared to
fight
in the town of clean just an hour
outside Moscow the next batch of freshly
mobilized say their goodbyes
I feel patriotism for my motherland that
is why I enlisted against Fascism and
Nazism does it feel like the right thing
to mobilize people in the country now
for you
yep
yep no
clean has a small town feel with a
patriotic Zeal brewed via State TV
that's typical outside the urban centers
they're proud of their boys heading to
the front and suspicious of British
journalists
sort out your own leadership issues
first then you can go around asking
questions you declare war on us you wait
till we are guests of yours
pro war field is not Universal even here
especially not amongst the Young
I won't go under any circumstances if I
have to I'll go to jail this shouldn't
have happened it's a crime what the
government is doing
on the way back to Moscow we pass yet
another war memorial Putin told his
people over and again never to forget
but he did not say never again
even though it's supposedly only partial
this is the first time that Russia has
declared a mobilization of troops since
World War II and the only time it did so
before that was for the first world war
and if Russia does annex these four
regions where it's held these sham
referenda then that will be the largest
land grab in Europe since World War II
and what will the death toll be when the
numbers are finally counted and will the
Russian people ever know how many of
their boys were sent off to fight in
some cases to die
news clean Russia